All of us spend so
much of our lives
tryingto make our
future selves happy.
We don't stop to ask, "Is it
possible that in 20 or 30years,
our future selves are
going to ask us,
"What made you possibly think
that that is whatI would want?".
We don't imagine, fundamentally,
that we're going to have
a different outlook or
a different perspective,
that we're going to be different people.
If you accept the idea that you're
goingto be a different person
in 30 years' time,
you should play an active role
crafting the personyou
are going to become.
You should be the curator
of your future self.
You should be the architect.
Expand your horizons,
because you're going to become
someone different,
you might as well be in
charge of deciding
who that person is going to be.